Well in the film, when asked by Spock, "Why are you climbing the mountain?"
Kirk says, somewhat facetiously, "Because it's there.",...
...a remark attributed to the climber Mallory.
Mountain is climbed, yes, because it's there,...
...because otherwise, you'll be walking on the plains.
But the mountain is climbed because I think the climber wants to hug the mountain.
He wants to envelop that mountain within his body.
He wants to make love to the mountain.
And on its highest and finest level,...
...whether these tough young guys with their sinewy bodies and their one-meal-a-day routine...
...will admit it, there is a passionate affair going on between the climber and the mountain.
Why do I climb the mountain?
I would say the climber would say, "Because I'm in love."